eeuu anunció que empezará a enviar un
pequeño número de tropas a europa mental
mientras continúan los esfuerzos
diplomáticos para evitar un conflicto
entre rusia y ucrania volodymyr selenski
llamó a occidente a no generar pánico
por la acumulación de tropas en sus
fronteras
la coalición gobernante en italia pidió
al presidente sergio mataré la que se
quede en el cargo tras seis días
consecutivos de votaciones infructuosas
en el parlamento para elegir al nuevo
mandatario una posibilidad que él mismo
descarta el proceso continúa en medio de
la profunda división entre los partidos
y en deportes la número uno del mundo as
libardi se coronó campeona del abierto
de australia la tenista local le dio a
su país el primer triunfo femenino en 44
años y se llevó su tercer título de gran
slam
actualizamos las noticias en france 24
gracias por acompañarnos mi nombre es
daniel hablando no comenzamos en eeuu el
presidente de joe biden dijo que enviará
un pequeño número de tropas al este de
europa un anuncio que mientras llegue
mientras llega mientras continúa los
esfuerzos diplomáticos para desde
escalar la crisis de ucrania por su
parte del presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski ha instado a los dos líderes
occidentales a evitar que cunda el
pánico por la masiva acumulación de
tropas rusas en su frontera
aviadores estadounidenses en la base de
la fuerza aérea de dover en delaware
cargan equipo bélico incluyendo armas y
municiones con destino a ucrania el
pentágono ha puesto en espera a unos
8500 soldados estadounidenses para un
posible despliegue en europa en medio
del incremento militar de rusia cerca de
la frontera con ucrania voy a trasladar
tropas estadounidenses a europa de la
estrella los países de la otan a corto
plazo
el jefe de las fuerzas armadas de los
eeuu dijo que el conflicto en ucrania
aún puede evitarse pero advirtió que
esta situación es diferente a las del
pasado
esto es mayor en escala de alcance en la
concentración de fuerzas que cualquier
cosa que hayamos visto en la memoria
reciente y creo que habría que
retroceder bastante los días de la
guerra fría para ver algo de esta
magnitud
los esfuerzos diplomáticos continúan
entre rusia y occidente el viernes el
presidente vladimir putin habló por
teléfono con su par francés emmanuel
macro los dos coincidieron en la
necesidad de desescalar pero putin
aseguró que la respuesta de eeuu y la
otan no tuvieron en cuenta las
preocupaciones fundamentales de rusia
entre ellas de impedir la expansión de
la otan y negarse a desplegar sistemas
de armas de ataque cerca de la frontera
de rusia más de 100 mil soldados rusos
están desplegados en la frontera con
ucrania y el presidente del país ha
pedido a líderes occidentales que eviten
el pánico ante el incremento militar
exchange a la sensación de los medios de
comunicación es que tenemos una guerra
que hay tropas en las carreteras que hay
movilización que la gente está yendo a
algún lado eso no es así
necesitamos este pánico
en una creciente tensión
moscú dijo el viernes por la noche que
había añadido a varios funcionarios de
la unión europea a la lista de personas
a las que se les ha prohibido la entrada
en rusia considerando los responsables
de políticas anti rusas nos quedamos en
esa región esta vez para hablar de kobe
19 en rusia el número de nuevos casos
diarios superó los 100.000 el sábado por
primera vez desde que inició la pandemia
con 113 mil 122 contagios el país
registró su novena jornada consecutiva
de récord una situación de la que las
autoridades culpan a la variante omicron
entretanto su vecino ucrania las muertes
por kobe 19 superaron la barrera de los
100.000 al tiempo que alcanzó un nuevo
récord de contagios con más de 37 mil
seguimos hablando del tema porque en
europa hubo una nueva jornada de
manifestaciones de los grupos
antivacunas en parís de cientos de
personas que se congregaron en los
alrededores de la torre eiffel para
protestar contra el pase vacunal y en
viena la capital austriaca miles de
activistas se oponen a la obligatoriedad
de las vacunas que entran en vigencia el
próximo primero de febrero el gobierno
anunció que a partir del 5 de febrero
relajara la mayoría de las restricciones
todavía vigentes pese a la persistente
subida de los contagios en la actual ola
de omikron
y el estancamiento en el parlamento
italiano continúa este sábado después de
que por sexto día consecutivo los
partidos políticos no lograran un
acuerdo para elegir al presidente de
este país el actual primer ministro
mario draghi habría pedido la
continuidad de sergio matar el a quien
hasta ahora ha descartado la posibilidad
también se baraja incluso la llegada de
una mujer al cargo
del lunes la misma historia se
desarrolla en el parlamento de italia
día tras día se cuentan las papeletas
para elegir el próximo presidente del
país y la conclusión es la misma
no se alcanzó la mayoría absoluta de los
integrantes de la asamblea es necesario
proceder a una nueva votación
los partidos de izquierda dicen que el
trabajo debería recaer en el actual
primer ministro mario draghi quien ha
sido aclamado por traer estabilidad al
país pero muchos temen que un cambio
abrupto del primer ministro a presidente
podría llevar al frágil gobierno de
coalición en italia al límite otros
bloques políticos se pelean por
encontrar un planeta el viernes los
partidos de derecha apoyaron a la
presidenta del senado elisabetta castle
a ti no lo habíamos candidata en cuanto
dos no la elegimos por ser mujer sino
como personalidad institucional y
profesional de confianza funcionaria
estatal con experiencia en el ámbito
judicial territorio de los datos no
experiencia y magistratura en la boca
tuvo russell a ti miembro del partido
forza italia de berlusconi es conocida
por su oposición al aborto y las uniones
entre personas del mismo sexo los
partidos de izquierda tildan su
nominación de error que la obtuvo solo
382 votos muy por debajo de los 505
necesarios para ganar
matar a él
mientras tanto partes del movimiento
cinco estrellas se están presionando
para que el presidente sergio mataré la
se quede pero el hombre de 80 años
insiste en que no quiere un segundo
mandato se acaba el tiempo para que el
parlamento encuentre su sustituto el
periodo de mataré la finalizará el 3 de
febrero
y en noticias deportivas por primera vez
en 44 años una australiana se corona
campeona del abierto de australia la
número uno del mundo as liberty esta vez
sí fue profeta en su tierra y se llevó
su tercer título de gran slam tras
imponerse al frente a su rival
estadounidense danielle él collins y
remontar un segundo set que perdía uno
por cinco con la victoria as libardi se
sumó a la estadounidense serena williams
como la única jugadora en activo en
haber ganado una competición slam en
tierra hierba y pista dura
para mí esto es un sueño hecho realidad
estoy muy orgullosa de ser australiana
así que gracias a toda esta multitud es
la más divertida ante la cual jugado
ustedes me han traído tanta alegría hoy
me relajaron me empujaron a hacer un
gran juego frente a una campeona como
danielle puede traer lo mejor hoy así
que muchas gracias por todo su amor y
apoyo en las últimas semanas
y finalizamos con moda este 29 de enero
se conmemora el aniversario número 60
del primer desfile del diseñador de moda
francés yves and love para celebrar los
seis museos de parís entre ellos el lujo
y el centro pompidou exponen sus diseños
junto a los cuadros que le sirvieron de
inspiración veamos
un vestido de yves al nuevo junto al
cuadro de pablo picasso que lo inspiró
sanz luego fue uno de los primeros en
llevar el museo a la pasarela a los 29
años el diseñador francés confecciona un
vestido que revolucionó la moda dando
vida a una de las composiciones de la
línea del artista holandés piet mondrian
[Música]
y añade una dimensión a la obra de
mondrian porque da movimiento a formas
que fueron creadas para ser estáticas y
ese es realmente el aspecto visionario
de lo que hizo
vestidos con los diseños de sandú o las
personas dan vida a las obras de arte
los bordados confieren a esta chaqueta
con forma de girasol la textura
empastada típica de la obra de van gogh
mientras que el estilo pixelado de este
cuadro de alan ya que se convierte en
una serie de patrones geométricos
el arte europeo no fue la única
inspiración de sant luego a finales de
los años 60 en sus viajes a marruecos
descubrió colores vivos y materiales
como los collares de madera y la rafia y
sin lujos diseñó este vestido en 1967
para la colección bambara que rindió
homenaje al arte africana vemos que la
modernidad es esencial para ello y la
encontró en el arte africano una mezcla
de tradición y líneas elegantes y
atemporal sanz luego también era
conocido por sus siluetas largas y
andróginas el mismo era un hábil
ilustrador la casa que compartía con su
marido pierre marie era su propio mini
museo lleno de obras que habían
coleccionado juntos saludo deja un
legado de una estética duradera la cual
consideraba más importante que la moda
si paramos
lo que importa es el estilo no la moda
porque la moda pasa pero el estilo
perdura
pero esto
[Música]
la obra de irsa novo ha influenciado en
generaciones de diseñadores que siguen
conjugando su moda con una alta dosis de
arte
con moda los dejamos gracias por su
sintonía
[Música]